Did he lose? He lost to Rob, too. Lil Bro can't even debate anymore.
Oh, boy. There's no way he lost to Rob, too, right? I would spend
I would spend so much money to prevent her from making any Oh,
this is like your This is your king of like facts and logic over
here, apparently. My god, the Rihanna Woo stuff. Is that really
a bombshell? Bro, it's so crazy. The entire world is all collaborating
against Destiny. There's like a massive cabal despite despite,
you know, all of us totally hating Rihanna Woo. She's also in
the cabal. Do you guys realize that? She's also in the
We switch right over to the Destiny stuff, guys. Right over right
now. Okay. So, the big thing that was going on, there's a couple
big things going on in the Pixie case. I believe that the court
transcript was sealed for 90 days, but also the motion for the
court transcript to be sealed 90 days seems to have been said
like uh until further notice. So that's a little weird,
right? So here we go. Look at this. And we see we basically have
um transcript of hearing held on this date.
So I'm going to set this up. Riyle really needs me to see this
Queen voice crack. Okay, it's incredibly We need to see it now.
We need to guys, there's a queen of voice
>> This is apparently the >> I'm basically one step
above a pan handler on the corner. Okay. And I don't pretend
otherwise. Guys, sub, donate, sub, donate. Okay. This isn't a
free show. All right. We're trying to make a living here. >> Oh,
just got a sub. Let's go. Thank you. Yes. That's every day.
>> man. I I just want to point out that's not even a voice
crack. To be fair, that's not a voice crack at all. What that
is is he has not spoken in like the past hour while he free boots
my content and plays a [__] video game. All right,
that's not a voice crack right there. He wasn't even talking.
That's him not using his voice for like a full hour. This piece
of this piece of [__] All right. Anyway, chain smoking
the whole time. True. So, uh I believe was today was the date.
transcript restriction set for
uh what o sorry September 4th. So apparently yesterday the transcript
was supposed to get released. Um I'm guessing this right here
sealed until further notice means it's actually documentary 90
sealed until further further notice. I I'm guessing it's just
going to stay sealed until something changes, right?
But uh so that was one thing that people thought were coming
out was coming out today that or yesterday. Sorry, it didn't.
But what did come out yesterday was Andrew Brettler doing a totally
response, maybe not. I actually haven't read it yet, but Andrew
Breler responds to Pixie trying to sanction Destiny uh for reading
that transcript live on food chops stream and
we get a ruling. Okay. Order granting 107 motion for lead to
file amended complaint. This okay, if you guys remember, if you've
been following at all, is the subject matter jurisdiction stuff.
So, you needed this complaint amended because realistically there's
probably an argument that there's not enough proof to pass a
summary judgement uh motion, a motion for summary judgement.
Okay, that there basically Destiny's team has been bringing up
that this court doesn't have subject matter jurisdiction repeatedly.
Under the law, the federal law that Pixie is suing Destiny for,
she needs a violation that happened after October of 2023.
the actual Rose leaks, the the Ro sending Rose the Pixie video
was done in April of 2023. Sorry, 2022. October 202022
and April of 2022. So, it was done in April of 2022. So, it's
about 6 months before the law was passed.
And because of that, technically under Cardi, there is no like,
you know, bulletproof evidence that Destiny sent the video after
Cardi was passed. They're arguing that because of that, because
this can't be considered a violation of Cardi because it happened
before the law was passed. And with all federal laws, uh, they
they don't go backwards. They don't, you know, um,
they don't go into the past, however you put that in terms of
legal things, but they're not retroactive. So, they need an instance
of some violation from after October of 2022. The Abby testimony
puts a violation in November of 2023, I think, right? Almost
a full year after. So that gets them past a, you know, a motion
to dismiss because they don't have subject matter jurisdiction.
If they can get that into their complaint, this right here is
an order on the motion for leave to file an amendment to the
complaint. The judge has supported that. The judge has said,
"Yes, you can you can uh file your compl." Sorry, you can amend
your complaint.
So, we'll read this cuz there are some good memes in here. Okay.
Some good memes. We got some memes coming. Of course, we need
a costume change real quick.
Of course. Of course. We're going to put the judge the judge's
wig on. Okay, let's go. Let's go. Let's go. All right. So, blah
blah blah blah blah.
United States District Court, Southern District of Florida.
Order on motion for leave to file leave to amend complaint. This
matter is before the court on plaintiff Jane Doe's motion for
leave to file an amended complaint. Docket entry 107. Defendant
time defendant timely responded docket entry 109 and plaintiff
timely respond replied docu entry 110. After careful consideration
of the motion, response, reply, relevant authority, and for the
reasons discussed below, plaintiff's motion for leave to amend
their complaint is granted.
So, this is basically going to make them, if they can amend it,
include this. I believe they'll mostly be immune to a motion
to dismiss,
right? I think they they mostly are immune to a motion to dismiss
at this point. Background. This case stems from what plaintiff
alleges is defendant's wrongful dissemination of a video of a
nature. video involving both Ms. Doe and Mr. Banell. Defendant,
for his part, alleges the situation was more complex in that
both plaintiff and defendant repeatedly shared similar materials
involving third parties with each other and that the practice
in effect extended to other individuals. Documentary 42 at 8-9.
It was then one of those other individuals, Rose, whose discord
account was allegedly hacked, which resulted in the leak of several
videos of a nature involving defendant, including the video.
Uh example is uh document entry 42-1. Presumptively due to the
nature of the case, the parties and their council have proceeded
to throw the proverbial kitchen sink at one another. This has
resulted in a litany of briefing before the court. These be yapping.
They're yapping. Of particular focus here is plaintiff's motion
for leave to file amended complaint documentary 107. In so filing,
plaintiff is seeking to preemptively address what defendant characterizes
as a lack of subject matter jurisdiction. In terms of briefing,
defendant has never proactively
filed a motion challenging the court's subject matter jurisdiction
over the case, but instead has raised it in in response to several
plaintiff's motions. See, for example, documentary 42 at 14,
documentary entry 109 at 4. I think these would be paragraphs.
Defendant's argument as to the lack of subject matter jurisdiction
is as follows. Plaintiff made the understandable mistake of misinterpreting
evidence regarding a Discord chat where defendant shared the
video with another individual as showing the that the conversation
took place in October of 2022 when it actually took place in
April of 2022. Documentary 42 at 14. The singular federal law
under which the plaintiff is claiming federal question subject
matter jurisdiction uh 15 USC 6851. Miss Cardi civil action relating
to the disclosure of intimate images or cardi uh only went into
effect on October 1st, 2022 and is not one that applies retroactively.
Documentary 109 at four. Hence, says defendant, Cardi cannot
be invoked here and there is no remaining federal claim giving
rise to the court's jurisdiction. Uh examples at paragraphs 4
and 5. Therefore, any amendment to the operative complaint would
be futile for want of jurisdiction. Uh ID at 57.
I don't know. I don't know what those references are. is saying
based on some former.
Okay.
Oh, do I need to Hold on. I need to zoom out a little bit so
the whole thing shows up. Can I
There we go. That's better. Better for you guys to see. Okay.
Okay. In response and though not conceding such that an
uh such an understandable mistake took place, plaintiff now seeks
to preemptively address any possible jurisdictional deficiency
by amending her operative complaint to add allegations regarding
the wider dissemination of the Google Drive where defendant is
alleged to have kept a trove of videographic material of a nature
including the video docket entry 107 at 3-4. This in addition
to a prior allegation from May 2025, the defendant also sent
the video to ABMC. See docket entry 48. And because says plaintiff,
the Google Drive was consistently available to many individuals
and that availability availability continued through the period
where Cardi took effect. Cardi indeed applies. This court has
jurisdiction to hear the case. An amendment is not futile. So
this was a big one where they were I I believe I believe they
thought they could dismiss based on this stuff not happening.
Um, I think he starts to address some of the other arguments
they've made and some of the other things. The Google Drive is
getting audited. This filter is so cooked. Uh, I don't know if
that's what this means yet. I don't it it will depend. Um, but
that's seems like it could be what it means. So, that would be
not great. Destiny getting aped. Brutally.
Brutally so. In response, oh, whoops. Whoops. Whoops. We're down
here. Applicable principles and law. The jurisdiction of federal
courts. Uh, so they have jurisdiction.
Amendments to pleadings, federal rules of civil procedure, blah
blah blah blah. I actually don't care about any of this. This
is all just legal mumbo jumbo. Um, do you want me to read this?
It's just going to be references to like why they have right.
It's going to say based on these principles in law, I'm going
to allow this.
Isn't that just Pixie's argument, not the ruling? No, this is
the ruling. This is not Pixie's argument. This is the ruling.
This is them saying, "Yes, we will allow you to amend the complaint."
This is the order on the motion. The order on the motion. You
know, maybe Riley is an AI summary. Well, I don't Sorry, it this
is just not going to be relevant. It's not going to be uh it'll
be relevant. Uh I'm just going to read jurisdiction federal courts.
Federal courts are courts of limited jurisdiction, meaning they
only have the power to provide a form for some, not all disputes.
See Morrison v. All State. Federal courts have limited subject
matter jurisdictions or in other words they have the power to
decide only certain types of cases. A district court can hear
a case only if it has at least one of three types of subject
matter jurisdiction. One jurisdiction under a specific statutory
grant. Two federal question jurisdiction pursuant to 28 USC section
1331 or three diversity jurisdiction pursuant to 28 USC section
Uh this is uh the citation uh citations and internal quotations
omitted. A federal court not only has the power but also the
obligation at any time to inquire into jurisdiction whenever
the possibility the jurisdiction does not exist arises. So if
they didn't have jurisdiction, it would be their responsibility
to to state so and they are supposed to examine this often. If
the court determines at any time that it lacks subject matter
jurisdiction, the court must dismiss the action. Amendments to
pleadings. Federal rules of civil federal rule of civil procedure
15A governs amendments to pleadings. A party may amend any pleading
once as a matter of right before a responsive pleading has been
filed or within 21 days after serving the pleading if no response
pleading is allowed. See Federal Rules of Civil Procedure 15A1.
In all other situations, the amending party must obtain written
consent from the opposing party or leave of the court to amend
the pleading. See Federal Rules of Civil Procedure 15A2. The
rule declares that to that leave to amend shall be freely given
when justice so requires. Uh, okay. So, that's they're basically
saying that if if
you have like a solid reason and to if to obtain justice, we
need to amend the pleading, we'll never block it. If the underlying
facts or circumstances relied upon by the plaintiff may be a
pro be a proper subject of relief, he ought to be afforded an
opportunity to test his claim on the merits. See Fman v. Davis.
Any amendments leading to a modification of the required pre-trial
scheduling order are subject to a good cause standard of scrutiny.
See federal rules of civil civil procedure parts
16B4
part page parts. Oh no. Federal rules of civil procedure 164.
That means that after the deadline for amending pleading set
forth in a scheduling order is passed, the party seeking the
amendment must show good cause and wide leave to amend the complaint
should be granted. See this case
district court need not allow an an amendment where allowing
the amendment would cause undue prejudice to the opposing party.
Um, okay. Of course, the grant or denial of an opportunity to
amend is within the discretion of the district court, but outright
refusal to grant the leave without any justifying reason appearing
for the denial is not an excuse of discretion. It is merely abuse
of that discretion and inconsistent with the spirit of federal
rules.
In the absence of any apparent or declared reason uh the leave
sought should as the rules require be further given. Substantial
reasons justifying the court a court's denial of the request
for leave to amend include undue delay,
bad faith or del uh dilitary motives on the part of the movement
and repeated failure to cure deficiencies by amendments previously
allowed. See this case, Burger King versus Weaver. Damn. Additionally,
district court may properly deny leave to amend when an amendment
would be futile. Analysis: The question of whether we have subject
matter jurisdiction is not so clear-cut as the parties would
have us believe. Accordingly, each party accuses the other of
not producing any evidence to support their respective claims
as to when defendant disseminated the video and to whom. Docury
1074. Despite defendants's lack of corroborating evidence for
this contention, documentary entry 109 at 4. Plaintiff has produced
no admissible evidence to demonstrate otherwise. As to plaintiff's
allegations that defendant transmitted the video to another individual,
AMBMC after the effective date of Cardi statute, defendant argues
that ABMC should have testified at an earlier June 3rd, 2025
hearing before the court that touched on, among other issues,
subject matter jurisdiction. Document entry 1095.
Defendant,
for his part, leans on his declaration as to the date formatting
the Discord chat primarily at issue. Plaintiff's mistake as to
the Discord chat having occurred on October 4th, 2022 is understandable.
In a screenshot of the transmission, the date of the communication
appears as 10:04 2022. C. Banell declaration paragraph 9 uh example
C. However, the date is reflected using the European time zone
as based on documentary 42 at 14. But Mr. Banell's declar declaration
then states that based on information belief, I've not sent the
video to anyone other than Rose. I certainly have not sent the
video to anyone since I sent the video to Rose on April 9th,
2022. Attached here to uh is exhibit C is a true and correct
copy of my Discord exchange with Rose dated April 9th, 2022,
beginning at 8:06 p.m. Eastern. On page two of the exhibit, because
it is a screenshot from Rose's side of the conversation, the
date of the transmission is reflected in European time format,
day, month, year, the timestamps on page two of the exhibit reflect
that Rose was corresponding from a time zone 5 hours ahead of
me in Miami, Florida. It was April 10th, 2022 at 10:06 a.m. UTC
when Rose and I began to correspond
or began corresponding regarding the video. Okay, so this is
people point this out as like uh Destiny is basically saying,
"Oh, I think she was like in the UK or some [__]
right? Because of the UTC time zone." I don't know if you can
really make that argument. Defendant also argues that plaintiff's
current allegations with respect to Abby when AbbyMC received
the video from defendant and corresponding proposed amendment
to the operative complaint are contradictory.
Compare documentary 481. ABMC describes defendant as sharing
a explicit video of himself and the plaintiff via Google Drive
link on November 3rd 2023 with documentary 107 uh 1, paragraph
14. Sometime in March 2023, Banell began messaging with a fan
of his on Instagram with the screen name ABMC. Over the course
of their ensuing relationship, Banell sent ABMC multiple explicit
videos, including the video through his Google Drive link. 15.
Sometime after receiving the video, ABMC messaged a friend of
hers and told her part leans on his declaration as to the date
formatting the Discord chat primary. Oh, sorry. Uh, told her
friend that Banell had sent her explicit video of the streamer
Pixie referencing the exhibit text message doc at docu 861.
To that end, defendant alleges that the proposed amendment amended
complaint now asserts as a ploy to establish jurisdiction that
sometime before November 3rd, 2023, defendant sent the link to
ABMC. Document entry 109 at 7. It merits noting that ABMC submitted
a signed declaration attesting to the transmission of the video
occurring on or about November 3rd, 2023. Documentary 77, documentary
entry 48, documentary entry 76 that both plaintiff and defendant
at times mischaracterize ABMC's honorabout testimony as occurring
on November 3rd, 2023 does not change her testimony, but does
not add but does add necessary context. In other words, the alleged
transmission of the video and message to a friend could well
have been two chronologically separate events that both align
with ABMC's honorabout testimony. The text of the chat snippet
at docket entry861 dated November 3rd, 2023 is consistent with
this. By the way, Destiny sends me tapes all the time and he
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. So, the alleged transmission
of the video could indeed have taken place on or about November
3rd, 2023 without making the allegations inherently
Okay, let's continue. We're continuing on from the previous paragraph,
which is about the time stamps. Okay, documentary 421, paragraph
9, emphasis and original. And for all of defendants protest that
ABMC should have testified at the hearing, noticeably absent
from defendants's arguments, generally regarding subject matter
jurisdiction and testimony is testimony from Rose that would
corroborate defendants's characterization of the Discord chat
in his declaration. A characterization that incorporates in exhibit
C a screenshot from Rose's Discord account that plaintiff could
not have obtained on his own from his side of the conversation.
Thus, as it stands at this stage of the case, the evidence purportedly
establishing a definitive timeline as to what defendant did or
did not do when uh and when is murky at best. Bro, is this is
this guy a snarker? Is this judge a snarker? Is he is he saying
why doesn't Destiny subpoena this person?
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Oh, also
by the way, I just kind of hope that they file So, you can file
ARA to update things, right? You can file ARA to update
filings. I believe in the in the amended complaint, they do list
Rose's age as 19. I do believe they should update that. We have
very clear information now to say she was 17. I think that should
be on the record as he reached out to the 17-year-old to them,
right? I think that's pretty clear. That's pretty obvious. is
that that should be a matter of public record. Absolutely. So
Pixie team, I don't know if Pixie is watching this. Okay, if
Pixie's team is watching this, update file whatever you need
to file to update that say to say, "Oh, small error. We listed
her age is 19. Her age is in fact
Let's go. Let's go. The Cabal judge is in cahoots with Jtock
and Dior. Okay. Well, yeah. Well, everybody's in the cabal. In
any event and under the circumstances, we need not reach a decision
on jurisdiction today. Defective allegations of jurisdiction
may be amended upon terms in the trial or appellet courts. 28
USC 1653 C. Con v. Burlington assessing whether the court of
appeals has subject matter jurisdiction and noting that plaintiffs
are usually able to amend their complaint even on appeal when
such jurisdiction is deficient. This provision like rule 15A
should be liberally construed. Leave to amend should be freely
granted when necessary to cure a failure to allege jurisdiction
properly. At this juncture, we need not reach an answer as to
jurisdiction because even if the plaintiff's jurisdictional allegations
were initially defective, the proper course in this instance
would be to grant leave to amend.
So they're basically saying without actually without actually
testing subject matter jurisdiction, I'm not making a ruling
on that. I'm going to say that I'm going to give them leave to
amend because your your argument against leave to amend is that
they don't have subject matter jurisdiction. I don't have to
solve that. If you truly believe they don't have subject matter
jurisdiction, then file file the dismiss. Okay, file the dismiss.
Based on the record before the court, there is nothing to suggest
plaintiff's motion is the result of undue delay dilatory dilatory
mo dilatory motive or in other or is otherwise in bad faith.
See well
uh 2007 WL this number. It is worth noting that plaintiff is
incorrect that she timely filed her motion to amend for which
the deadline per document entry 23 was July 6, 2025, document
entry 23 at 1, documentary 107 at 3. That said, plaintiff filed
on July 7th, 2025.
And we are loathed to consider that single day as undue delay
or dilitary motive. And it is true that defendant has been raising
the question of subject subject matter jurisdiction in various
responses to plaintiff's motions and thus cannot be surprised
at and should not be unduly prejudiced by plaintiff's request
for leave to amend.
Oh, so
basically the only real cause for not allowing amendment would
be that he would be prejudiced. But it's like you've been aware
you've been making this argument, right? Basically, for amended
complaints, judges tend to favor allowing them since it basically
lets the plaintiff make the best version of their case and the
defendant oppose the strongest version with the strongest defense.
Well, Free Pie, yes. Sorry, I'm reading Free Pie's message here.
Yes,
I think it's it's basically just like
why would we make you refile this, right? Like obviously they've
gone through a bunch of administrative effort to get this through
the courts already. Why would they make you refile it and like
make everybody like we've already spent judges time on this.
just amend the complaint, we'll continue. It's not like it's
a totally different case. It's just especially for subject matter
jurisdiction, right? Okay. So, it's worth noting that she doesn't
have dilatory motive. I will say uh I believe that Destiny's
team argued this multiple times that she's uh she's just spamming
Desi's argued this colloquially as well that she's just spamming
motions and she doesn't want to do anything and she's like she's
way behind on this and she didn't say anything about it and like
they're just [__] with me. But the judge says, "No,
she's not [__] with you." And this is like, "Fine,
and you kind of expected this. You've been motioning to say that
she doesn't have s subject matter jurisdiction. You can't be
shocked that she's filed for leave to amend her complaint." Obviously,
and it's true that the defendant has been raising this question.
Blah blah blah blah. Can't prejudice him. See docket entry 42
at 14. The parties have even mutually elected to somewhat pause
discovery pending the court's resolution of plaintiff's motion
for protective order. Disc entry 82, docket entry. Docket entry
107 at three. Number one, thus as leave to amend should be further
given in the absence of substantial reason to deny leave. Bryant
uh F3D
I don't know what this means. F3D third district or something
at 1163 plaintiff's motion for leave to file her amended complaint
is granted
granted. Okay, it's all good. They made it work. Should defendant
believe after the filing of plaintiff's amended complaint that
this court still does not have subject matter jurisdiction, defendant
is free to file a 12b1 motion or otherwise generally respond
to plaintiff's briefing arguing as much.
So this is him saying if you actually believe she doesn't have
subject matter jurisdiction, if you want a ruling on that because
you haven't filed anything, then actually file something, right?
It's like even if she didn't have subject matter jurisdiction,
which this complaint solves, or sorry, amending should solve
unless there's like evidence proving otherwise, you should just
file the dismiss.
I believe Destiny's had the ability to file the dismiss this
whole time. I actually believe it's possible like Destiny himself,
right? I don't know when they started talking to Abby or when
they figured this out. But it's possible that if he filed to
um dismiss
they might have just seen that
uh got that through the court and been forced to reply with no
response from Abby. Like I don't know when Abby came in, but
it was like quite a bit later. They might not have they might
not have been aware of Abby until like weeks or months after
the initial complaint was filed. And I think he just he the reason
he gave for not filing one was it was expensive. That judge was
in the Kiwi Farms thread. Case dismissed. Oh no, I hate Kiwi
farmer judges.
Conclusion. For the fourgoing reasons, plaintiff's motion for
leave to amend is granted.
Docket entry 107. Plaintiff shall promptly file a first amendment
complaint. First amended complaint on the docket. Done and ordered
in chambers at Miami, Florida this 4th day of September, 2025.
Edwin G. Torres. Eddie
well-known Kiwi farmer Eddie Torres. So, what do we got here
around this? Um, there's this there's the Andy B thing as well.
I think there was like some zip zip cope on this, wasn't there?
He talked about it twice. I think there's a couple good clips
on this. Let me see. I think Ry sent me something here. Starting
time stamp on YouTube.
Okay, so they amended it, but they still provided their evidence.
Guess the magic can throw it out now or what? Um well now um
I think now we could either reply or we could do a motion to
dismiss. I think now we try to do a motion to dismiss.
Basically the only thing now is um they're trying to say that
they're well now they've walked back a little bit. The date on
the um sending the file to the to Rose. They walked back on that
and saying they're saying that the debate is now um in contention.
>> Wait, what is that the word I'm looking >> They
walked back on that. Did Pixie's team file more?
I thought this is just based on the I think the judge just ordered
something. I thought the only change here is the judge made their
order. What? What did
>> It's not. Uh I think the plaintiff's own filings like
in their own filings there were picked. >> Oh, right. Yes.
Free pie. This is This is what it is. So the NDB filing which
is a So there's one other thing here. Do I have court listener
up still? I don't. Hold on. Court listener Dove vibbanel.
so we go to the bottom of this. There is the response in opposition
to plaintiff's motion for order to show cause why ident defendant
should not be held in contempt. Request for sanctions and injective
relief filed by Steven Kanel II. So Pixie's team basically said
this went and read the sealed transcript verbatim on a stream.
Can you not? Can you not? Did you see the food shops bombshells?
No, did not see those. Uh, there's a footnote in the amended
complaint saying they were unsure when the messages to Rose were
sent. Oh, they filed their amended complaint now, didn't they?
Yeah, they filed their amended complaint. They need to file an
AA for this and say, "Oh, we up and just make sure they tweak
um tweak Rose's age to 17 here." There's also a coat from Bretler
filing saying Pixie is the one talking about the case all the
time. Well, she does talk about the case a little bit, but just
not anywhere near. Oh, the Rihanna Woo stuff. Is that really
a bombshell? Bro, it's so crazy. The entire world is all collaborating
against Destiny. There's like a massive
despite despite, you know, all of us totally hating Rihanna Woo.
She's also in the Cabal. Do you guys realize that she's also
in the Cabal? No way. No way. Of them looking at dates that say
like 20 27-05-
So like it's pretty these are European dates, I think, by plain
evidence. So, the only thing that it'll come down to is um whether
or not um is whether or not the
uh the how what goes on with this Abbeby person, I guess, is
the only thing. The mysterious Abbeby MC, whoever that is, would
you not motion to dismiss the whole time? >> The motion
to dismiss on the initial complaint, but the problem is it I
mean, it should have survived. like they had a lot of they had
a lot of claims and accusations in there, but now that we're
through this a bit, they amended their complaint super late.
Just to be clear, they had a chance at motion to dismiss before
this. Uh, as far as I know, the judge didn't take their argument
that Abby should have testified seriously. He said, "Why don't
you go get Rose to testify?" Right?
Like there's like essentially nothing
nothing he's saying here is accurate, right? They had a lot of
claims and accusations in there, but now that we're through this
a bit, they amended their complaint super late. They haven't
provided any evidence of >> they yeah, one day late and
the judge literally said we don't think it's with undue delay.
So that that's already the judge has already given the perspect
the court's perspective on this was not >> Any of the other
random things that they've had in there, they threw like even
more wrong dumb, but at this point I figured now it's just beneficial
to me. You just want to load it up with a bunch of stupid stuff.
Um, it's good for me, I guess. Um
I dude
the the is so funny. Like it doesn't matter what actually happens
in the case. He's like uh Andrew Wilson. Like just there's no
there's no connection to reality, right? Just zero connection
to reality.
It's great times now. It's just beneficial to me. You just want
to load it up with a bunch of stupid stuff. Um it's good for
me, I guess. Uh but the only thing that matters that it all comes
down to now is the Abby stuff. Um,
>> uh, I don't think that's true actually. I think they
amended something with the Google Drive saying that Google Drive
was persistent through the date. I actually don't think it all
comes down to Abby anymore,
right? That they're saying there's a there's evidence of this
like Google Drive or something. I think that's amended and added
to the complaint. >> Yeah. You can file for dismissal.
I mean, like it might it I'm get want a motion to dismiss. You're
looking at the pleading and you're accepting it. >> Oh,
wait. This time stamp is only from today. I thought the Zip Zip
Cope was yesterday, wasn't it? Yeah, we missed the Zip Zip Cope.
Hold on. I've got like Zip Zip Cope somewhere. Zip Zip came on
and talked to Destiny about how it was like actually good for
them. Hold on. This is today. I need the the Zip Zip cope. Where'd
that Zip Zip cope at? Hold on. I can find it. Give me a second.
Uh lawsuit memes from yesterday. They got their motion, but uh
it's pretty good for you. I haven't started
you. Presumptively, due to the nature of the case, the parties
and their council have proceeded to throw the proverbial kitchen
sink at one another. This is just all that, dude.
>> You got to read it after. Holy [__] I feel
like 90% of the motions have been followed by them. I'm pretty
sure they have been. Okay. Jesus. [__] Maybe I'll
[__] read it. Did you read the whole thing? Is it
a good read? >> I'm pretty much finishing it. It's a >> Brler
spam some replies, too. Brler Brentler's got to pat out those
billing hours. Okay. Does complaint being amended mean that anyone
he sent the Google Drive link to is subject to discovery? Sorry,
I'm mad out of my field here. No, I I mean I think it's his Google
Drive would just be open to discovery, possibly, but I think
they'd have to have evidence of this. The thing is, I don't think
they have evidence of this because I believe that they literally,
unless they have some other evidence, they haven't submitted,
but they literally are just alleging this. And if they allege
it off of the Rose stuff, the Rose leaks, those were done over
Discord. And I thought they were alleging it off of the leaks
over Discord. So
they they got their motion, but uh it's pretty good for you.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Oh, no. No, it is because Yeah. Okay.
Okay. I'll go through this. All right. >> Yeah. Yeah. Don't
>> The matter is before the court on >> I don't know
what this is. I I guess most people just don't really read this
stuff or look into it, right? Oh, no. It's really good for you.
Don't mention it. Don't mention it. Don't mention it. It's like
what are you what are you >> Thank what don't read it.
>> Why wouldn't you Why wouldn't you want to just like
talk about why your case is strong? I guess I don't know. >> No,
whatever. >> The matter is before the court on plaintiff
Jane Doe's motion to for leave to file a minute complaint. Defendant
timely responded and plaintiff timely responded after consideration.
The motion response reply relevant authority. Okay. Why the [__]
did I read this if I was just going to go over this for the recess
motion please amend her complaint is granted. So motion to um
amend the complaint just allows them to >> Hey, give me
a second. I'm going to use the bathroom and get some water really
quickly. I might get caffeine actually cuz we got two more hours.
I'll get caffeine.
Um, I was going to go back and look, but I think they just want
to add
>> which is what they're Wait, what? Oh, >> Abc and
the Google Drive thing. >> And that second one has got
some >> Wait, hold on. >> Can I Can I Can I meme
for one microcond? Hold on. >> Oh, boy. >> It's funny
because a hater
DM me this, but hold on. I have a question. >> Let's see.
What is it? >> Because it wouldn't do that, would it? >> Uh,
you're probably right, but it uh I don't think it necessarily
matters. H well they would have to I think it would >> be
because they're saying that with >> Yeah. Oh well they
try to incorporate the disc but but they'll never win on that.
Even the drive link I think there's already precedent that that
argument is stupid but on the Well but that doesn't matter. Hold
on. >> I I agree it doesn't but >> Well no I'm saying
for her in particular. Um >> yeah but they're just using
it but I think because >> they want to use the driver because
they don't that means that everything rides >> Yeah. But
the the idea is that if it's true then it existed before.
>> Is that is that even necessarily true? How would they
have to prove it? >> That's their Yeah, >> that's
Oh, maybe I have to go through and reread the motion. I don't
know. Or I mean, I've already I feel like I probably
Okay. Sorry. All right. Anyway, we're back. Okay. This case stems
from what plaintiff alleges the defendant's wrongful dissemination
of a video of a nature involving both Misto and Mr. Banell. Defendant
for his part alleges that the situation was more complex and
that both plaintiff and defendant repeatedly shared similar materials
involving third parties with each other and the practice um and
that practice in effect extended other individuals. It was then
one of those other individuals rose whose discord account was
allegedly hacked. So, if I had to guess at what they were discussing
there, I feel like they're discussing the make available or continuous
publishing elements, right? I think that's probably what they
were talking about there. And like I think that it sounded like
Destiny thinks that that shouldn't matter and it should just
matter when you like originally sent or something, but it would
depend I suppose on like if you could do access logs and for
the Google Drive, right? I don't know. I don't know. I think
I think that's what they're discussing. of several videos involving
a defendant, including the video. Presumably, due to the nature
of the case, the parties and their council have proceeded to
throw the proverbial kitchen sink at one another. This has resulted
in a litany of briefings before the court. A particular focus
here is plaintiff's motion for leave to file a meta complaint.
In so filing, plaintiff is seeking to preemptively address what
defendant characterizes as a lack of subject matter jurisdiction.
In terms of briefing, defendant has never proactively filed a
motion challenging the court's subject matter jurisdiction of
a case, but instead has raised it in response to several of plaintiff's
motions. Defendant's argument as to the lack of subject matter
jurisdiction is as follows. plaintiff made the understandable
mistake of misinterpreting evidence regarding a discord chat
where defendant shared the video with another individual as showing
that the conversation took place in October 2022 when it actually
applies to act. Um so basically so as I've said before we don't
have diversity jurisdiction we're both in the same place the
proper venue proper jurisdiction would be um the Florida court
this federal law is the only thing that gives subject matter
jurisdiction to allow it to be in federal court and also all
of the underlying things that she's trying to are unhinged and
actually stupid. So like they require like malicious intent.
Um so this this subject matter jurisdiction question is paramount.
It's the most important question that we're addressing right
now. Therefore any amendment to the operative complaint would
be futile for want of jurisdiction.
In response and though not conceding that such an understandable
mistake took place, plaintiff now seeks to preemptively address
any possible jurisdictional deficiency by amending her operative
complaint to add allegations regarding the wider dissemination
of the Google Drive where defendant is alleged to have kept a
trove of videographic material of a similar nature including
the video the 107
in addition to a prior allegation from May. >> I'm not
sure I've ever man I I don't really know if that is I know this
existed. Desi talked about it existing. I know for a fact that
he did share Google Drive folders with people that had all like
a bunch of stuff in it. I don't know if he shared the same Google
Drive link with everybody all the time. If he just had like an
open Google Drive where he could share with anyone. I knew I
knew that. No, I was shaking a shaker cup with like caffeine
mixed with water. Um like caffeine powder flavored powder stuff,
but um I do know he shared Google Drive links. I don't know if
it was like everything. I have no idea exactly, but um
so it's interesting. I think they could easily get evidence of
this that Destiny like I I think that exists like people who
would testify that he sent them Google Drive links instead and
like drive as in like the folder not like a not a file but a
folder with like a bunch of videos in it. I don't know if that
included the Pixie thing. I have no idea. I feel like that if
they have that evidence they should be able to go through uh
they should be able to go through Yeah.
2025. The defendant also sent the video to Abby Mc and because
it says plaintiff the Google Drive was consistently available
to many individuals and that availability continued through the
period where Cardi took effect. Cardi indeed applies. This court
has jurisdiction to hear the case and amendment is not futile.
Um would be >> what they're saying? >> What you understand
what the judge is saying here? >> What do you mean? They're
the they're just laying out the arguments from both
>> Oh, kind of. Yeah. >> Well, they're they're saying
that it's it's true what the plaintiff is saying. It it is kind
of so like it it doesn't matter if they amend the complaint because
e um it's just adding to the the whether jurisdiction is there.
>> Yeah. Wait, what? The judge is just walking through
the judge summarizing what the plaintiff why the plaintiff wants
to amend the complaint, right? >> Well, the last part they're
agreeing with the plaintiff. They're they're granting it. >> Be
reasonable to assume that Rose's videos could have been on the
Google Drive and access also accessible by anybody. I don't know.
Like I I've never heard of I don't know if Destiny kept stuff
with just other people in the same Google Drive. I don't I don't
know if I've heard of that.
>> Yeah, I don't know if I've heard of >> And because
says plaintiff and because says plaintiff that the Google Drive
is consistent available by many individuals and that availability
continue through the period regarding took effect indeed applies.
Uh semicolon this court has jurisdiction of the case amendment
is not futile.
>> Um I don't know if the court's making determination
at that point. I think it just I think these are claims of the
plaintiff, right? They're going to guess what it might
that would be that would be a thing that we would fight on because
the case on that is like clearly cuts in our direction and the
that would be like a that would be that would be a >> big
All you're saying is that the
>> uh I don't know if that would be a big change if he
was making the folder available to people, right? Those would
be every time he's sharing the folder. I don't think just the
folder existing is proof of continuous continuous publishing,
but then you would need access to all of his Discord DMs looking
for other instances of sharing that same folder link, right?
I think that's the big deal. >> The amendment isn't futile,
so we're going to they're going to get to it >> Uh yes,
Cam the Jelly Man. Yes, that exists with I believe I believe
that is Richard Lewis and Dan and Destin's also talked about
how he's a big Google Drive
>> At least I mean it would survive it would survive the
complaint the pleading stage, right? Wait, did I say Richard
Spencer or Richard Lewis? I meant Richard Lewis, but I might
have said Richard Spencer >> because you have to assume
it's true. That's true. Yes. Okay. Sure. So, agreed in so far
as it would it would prefer
survive, I guess, a motion to dismiss because it would satisfy
the um jurisdictional aspect. That's true. Sure. Okay. Applicable
principles and law the jurisdiction of federal courts. Federal
courts are courts of limited jurisdiction, meaning they only
have the power form for some, not all disputes of
They should just let him amend it because if it's true then it
would be the subject matter decision. It would >> kind
of yeah you assume yeah assumed to be true but if yeah if true
then sure yeah um amendments to pleadings wait analysis question
of >> so I think zip zip right there explains why this
will survive subject matter jurisdiction right like a motion
to dismiss cuz for a motion to dismiss you go actually even if
what they said was true they wouldn't have like subject matter
jurisdiction here
this is the wrong venue for this that's how they're trying to
dismiss but if it is true they do have subject matter jurisdiction
So, okay. Analysis. All right. Um, so here they're basically
just saying that like basically as long as the plaintiff isn't
like super round or whatever, like you should generally be given
the opportunity to amend your complaint at least one time. >> And
if the stuff that they're trying to amend is true, then there's
then they should just let them amend it cuz if it's true, then
it would be the subject matter. It would be >> kind of
Yeah. You assume Yeah. Assume to be true, but if Yeah. If true,
then sure. Yeah. Um, amendments to pleadings. Wait, analysis.
Question of whether we have subject matter jurisdiction is not
so clear-cut as the parties would have us believe. Accordingly,
each party accuses the other of not producing any evidence to
support the respective claims as to when defendant disseminated
the video and to whom despite defendants's lack of corroborating
evidence for this contention dot dot dot plaintiff has produced
no admissible evidence to demonstrate otherwise as a plaintiff's
allegations that the defendant transmitted the video to another
individual ABMC after the effect of the party statute. Defendant
argu should have testified at an earlier June 3rd 2025 hearing
before the court that touched on among other issues subject matter
jurisdiction. Um let's see defendant also claimed of current
allegations when ABMC received the video from defendant corresponding
proposed amendment to the operative complaint arc third with
me a friend of hers and told her Jesus Christ this footnote.
Oh my god. All this part says is we don't know the exact date
that it doesn't matter. It's it would have to be after the >> that
defendant alleges amendment complaint now asserts as a deploy
to establish
logical system. Okay. Chat having occurred on for his part leans
on his declaration as the date formatting of dates here but you
know that' be nice. Um okay defendant uh for his part leans on
his declaration as the date formatting of the discord chat primarily
issue. Plaintest mistake as the discord chat having occurred
on October 22 understandable in a screenshot of the transmission
the date. >> Hold on hold on hold on. Does he skip? There's
no way he skips right. There's no way he skips. Oh, no, no, no,
he
>> Wow, be nice. Um, okay. Defendant uh for his part leans
on his declaration as the date formatting of the discord chat
primarily at issue. Plaintest mistake as the discord chat having
occurred on October 42 is understandable and a screenshot of
the transmission the date of communication appears as 10:04 2022.
However, the data time zone circulation then states that based
on information belief, I haven't sent the video to anyone other
than Rose not the video anyone since I sent the video to Rose
on April 9th, 2022 attached here is a true and correct copy of
my data April 922 beginning at 86 a.m. H2 because
he's he's speaking really fast here about sending to a minor
in April of 2022
conversation the daily transmissions.
>> Dude, he's speaking so fast.
It was April 10th. Um, when was I corresponding
10th? Oh, they should say April 9th. Oh, they might have mixed
up the Oh, no, no, no, wait. It was April 10th at 106 April 10th
in UTC.
>> Wait. Yeah, because it was April 10th, 2022 at 106 a.m.
UTC, which Okay, where are we? Okay. and for all defendants protest
that IBMC should have testified at the hearing notably absent
from defendants arguments generally regarding subject matter
restrictions from Rose that would corroborate defendants characterization
discord chat in his well I'm not the person what how am I am
I supposed to trying to subpoena this person bring them >> keep
going yeah keep going >> a characterization that incorporates
an exhibit C a screenshot of Ros's discord account the plaintiff
could not have obtained on his own from his side of the conversation
um and exhibit C a screenshot from Rose okay thus as it stands
at this stage in the case the evidence reportedly subive timeline
as what defendant did or did not do and when Murky at best. That's
good for me, I think. Um, in any event, and when is murky at
best. That's good for me, I think. Um, in any event, >> kind
of I'll DM it. >> Sure. In any event and under >> Yeah,
kind of. I'll DM you. Not really. Is I Am I the only one who
heard that? Yeah, it's kind of good. I'll DM you. >> Is
that good? >> The circumstances, we need not reach a decision
on jurisdiction today. Oo, that's spooky for them, I think. um
defective allegations of jurisdiction may be amended upon terms
in the trial or appellet courts. They've used you only get one
amendment to the complaint as well, right? So this is it. They
this is their one amendment and then we fight here and they can
no long
>> No, I think it's like you should be guaranteed one amendment
and then I think amendments after that need to be subject to
good cause, right? I still believe that you would try to get
justice as best as possible, right? believe they can amend the
complaint any longer.
In any event under these circumstances, we need to reach a decision
on jurisdiction. We don't. Okay. Defective allegations jurisdiction
matter and noting that plaintiffs are usually able to make the
complaint even on appeal. One such jurisdiction is deficient
on this provision like um >> what I'm saying. >> Um
wait, >> is he not going to read this out loud?
>> Oh, I can't possibly provide that though, right? Because
I'm pretty sure that person deleted their account, >> Doesn't
want to read that out loud. Noticeably absent noticeably absent
from defendants's arguments generally regarding subject matter
jurisdiction is testimony from Rose that would corroborate defendants
characterization of the Discord chat in his declaration. Do you
not know who this Rose person is? Well, he could argue that before.
Ah. Oh, no. Wait.
>> You know what? You getting >> Oh, wait. No, I
can do because I have both sides of a screenshot because the
guy posted them all. Oh,
yes. He the judges understand that. Oh, that's so easy. Okay.
>> Yeah. So, that's it. That's done. Okay. So, I just need
So, now it's just the the brain damage. >> It's just saying,
"Hey, let's just
>> We can't move on from it yet, but let's >> Yeah.
But what he's saying is it would be nice if there was a screenshot
from
>> I think the rest of us have moved on from this and just
said that under this you wouldn't have subject matter jurisdiction,
right? I think we've all moved on from this and we're like, "Yeah,
this is obviously they need other stuff, right?" Yeah. I think
I think they're the only people who have moved on from >> Rose's
Discord account that plaintiff that I could not have obtained
on my own. What the judge doesn't realize is that the screenshots
are coming from her account. So I just need to post them from
my side now and then he'll have both sides of it. You can see
there is no discrepancy on the date there. Okay. Thus at the
stage of the case the evidence. Okay. In any event and under
the circumstances we need not reach. Okay. I've read this like
three times. Court of Appeals is noting the PL this provision
like a leave to amend should be fail grant when necessary to
care failure they were initially defect of the proper course
in this instance will be to grant leave to amend based on the
record before the court there's nothing to suggest plaintiff's
motion is the result of undue delay dilatory motive or is otherwise
in bad faith um for the amendment to um uh for the mo for to
to take leave to amend the complaint I think is probably true
hopefully they don't say this on all of them but okay
I mean I've seen From all of the other motions, I don't think
there's any evidence of dilatory motive or being in bad faith.
I'm sorry. You went and read verbatim from that transcript, my
guy. You're clearly reading.
Or maybe, hey, maybe that is not like the one to one. I dude,
I feel like it's very clear he's just reading directly from the
transcript. And they allege that he is reading directly from
the transcript. If he's reading one to one from the transcript,
I think he's
on that one. I think they will. I think they they basically have
to sanction him, right? Um, it's worth the plaintiff is incorrect
that she timely filed her motion to amend for which the deadline
per was July 6th, 2025. That said, plaintiff filed on July 7th,
2025. And we are loaded to consider that single day as undue
delay or dilatory motive. And it is true that defendant has been
raising the question of subject matter jurisdiction in various
responses to plaintiff's motions and thus cannot be surprised
at and should not be unduly prejudiced by PL's request for leave
to amend. parties should have the parties should have even mutually
elected to somewhat pause discovery pending the court's resolution
of plaintist motion protective order thus as leave to amend should
be freely given in the absence of substantial reason to deny
leave plaintist motion for leave to file her amended complaint
granted should defendant believe after the filing amended complaint
that the court still doesn't have subject matter jurisdiction
defendant is free to file a 12b1 motion otherwise generally respond
oh my god the 12b1 is a motion to dismiss right am I dismiss
yeah they're saying you can do a motion to dismiss or you can
just respond to >> just to be clear Destiny has himself
talked about and is clearly also
in
that he's been able to file a motion to dismiss the entire time.
Literally the entire time he's never not been free to file a
motion to dismiss. It's very funny, right, that like
he's
he's pretending like, "Oh no, I can finally file a motion to
dismiss." No, he literally talked about why he didn't file one
before even though it was suggested to him and that was because
it would have been expensive.
I don't want to just pay for that guys. It would be a lot of
money >> to the actual allegations
>> but now I would want to now it's absolutely it's a time
to fight on a motion dismiss and then I and then I still got
my summary judgement later.
>> For the reasons. Okay. Okay. Plenty of first amendment
complaint on the docket.
Thank god. Okay. This is going to about to be my most hardcore
research legal reply ever. >> Oh, because you're representing
yourself, right? As uh as we >> No, I'm just I'm about
to send my lawyers like four trillion pages of notes for everything.
>> Yeah, it's it's it's good for you. Obviously, they they
granted it for
plaintiff, but >> It's not. >> Okay. Boom. Boom.
Boom. Boom. >> Don't you have your debate in like 4 >> Yeah.
I'm getting all my documents in
>> I guess. Getting all those documents. >> Was there
much more here? Oh, there's a new Oh, I didn't even see that.
I got to read that in a minute, too. Oh, holy >> Oh, it's
our response to them trying to They want to sanction me $10,000
plus her attorney's fees for talking on
this because the Kiwi Farms.
They're so funny.
>> Oh, and my I >> because the Kiwi Farms No, because
you went on stream and directly read from the transcript. They
want to sanction me because of the Kiwi Farm. No, that's not
what they want to do. We pushed for sanctions in that motion
as well in our
>> Has this whole situation hurt Desty's stream? It seems
like it had no effect on his audience. Uh, I don't know about
that. Was this like his his playboard stream thing? So, he was
he was kind of going good for a little bit here and then was
it around the middle of August started around
around the time they discovered the rose. He started dropping
to like 5k average, 4k average, 5k average, 5k average, 6k average.
He's had some rough streams since. It's been not great. This
one was uh he got botted during this conversation or during this
day, but other than that day, it's been like I don't know, kind
of steadily not in a great spot in terms of the YouTube numbers.
Seems to have fallen off quite a bit uh in terms of live stream
numbers, but it's been since the Rose stuff. The Rose stuff seemed
to have hurt him. Apparently, YouTube has also been cracking
down on bots. That might be part of it. Oh, interesting. >> in
our brief to their motion and our response. So, there he goes.
Okay. Um I'm going to rest him and then I'll hop in and
>> Okay. So that's it for that one and then this is the
next day >> and then um
looking it all comes down to now is the Abby stuff. >> I
think his kick numbers do f fluctuate though that he would be
done for after this thing. Why?
No. Literally people were posting in this community like uh child
doesn't matter bro
he's still cool. Not even child can make me stop watching Destiny.
That's unironically a post from Mantis in the community is like
not even child not even getting found to have child could stop
him. It's like uh but it should that you shouldn't be celebrating
that. That should be concerning. That should scare you.
That's the weirdest post.
>> Yeah. You can file for dismissal. I mean like it might
it
pleading and you're accepting it as though it's true. And then
um >> Oh, so he accepts that the motion to dismiss would
not even be like there's no reason to do a motion to dismiss
at this point. >> If the um that's it. So that's why if
if somebody dismisses a case on a motion to dismiss, you've probably
up uh quite a bit. So
whether I don't know if we can dismiss it. We'll see.
Oh, it's so much better that we watched it today and we got to
watch the
from yesterday and then the the destruction of the cope today.
Okay. Oh, it's way better that way. Let's go. >> Depends,
I guess, on the Abbe stuff. But the MSJ, the motion for summary
judgement, I imagine is probably like that should be it should
be an easy one. I guess again it's just going to come down to
the to the how much the judge thinks that Aby's testimony with
no evidence is
I guess a matter of fact versus a matter of law. >> Wait,
is that something that like
a motion for summary judgement is is basically alleging that
there are no facts left in contention, right? So if you're not
willing to go to trial and produce this evidence, how do you
win on a motion for summary judgement? How do you get granted
summary judgement if whether or not she he sent the video to
Abby is still in contention? How could you how could you win
a am I missing something? Latigious Gamer or any lawyers in chat?
I believe a motion for summary judgement is saying there are
no more material facts in contention. Can you please judge this
instead of sending it to a
a jury, right? But it seems like there are still major facts
in contention.
Are you able to get transcripts yet? Uh nope. Still waiting on
the ruling on that. What is the Abby stuff specifically? Destiny,
I missed that. Um, I was unaware of this, but when Abby was at
my place in 2023, Abby was apparently after I left, she got on
my computer and started snooping through
no evidence of that. Oh, unless he maybe he has evidence of that.
He probably does keep like
maybe there is evidence of that or something. Okay,
but then why would he not have produced that? I I don't know.
The evidence that I've seen is basically she takes a picture
at his computer and says, "Big leak's coming." Right.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Holy xray. She has a text to Darius
with a picture at his computer saying, "Oh, big leaks coming."
But then to me, I don't know why you don't just produce the rest
of those logs. Where are the big leaks? She did. Surely there
must be big leaks. No. In the process of that, I guess maybe.
I don't know. Um because I didn't know this until a couple months
ago. Supposedly she went through my folders on my computer and
looked at stuff. And uh supposedly according to who? Who said
Wait.
Supposedly according to who? Well, I think Moonray Murray. It
seems like she's taking a picture of his screen including like
one of his Discord screenshots or something like he's got Discord
up. Sorry. And she takes a picture of that. And so you would
assume big leaks coming would be like uh like oh I might be take
a picture of something that is leaking. I just I don't know what
evidence there is beyond that. But maybe he's got some or maybe
that's the only evidence he's got. He's just to me he would he's
always been the guy who produces evidence when he has it. Right.
Like when Willie Mack accused him of having 60 GB of child he
immediately pulled that log of Rose or sorry yeah Rose saying
actually we have 60 GB of photo sets. So now he's just like creative
writing. >> Two months later she there's a DM. This is
the only evidence they submitted. But two months later she's
like talking to a friend saying, "Oh, Destiny sent me all these
videos of him banging um and then he names Cherry and Pixie,
of which I I I don't even have videos of the form. That's not
even true. So my guess is is that she just went through stuff
on my computer and saw names that she recognized and she was
just like talking [__] to a friend." But she's trying
to say that I sent her um whatever video of Pixie in 2023 or
something, but I never have. I don't have any logs of it. There's
no they haven't provided any proof of that. And at the hearing,
they even said that Abby didn't have any proof of that. They
just had that one DM, which I don't know. This was literally
the the whole thing. It's not just one DM, but the whole thing
was uh the whole thing was always based on she has contemporaneous
messages saying Desty sent me video a video pixie, right? It's
contemporaneous evidence >> that Abby didn't have any proof
of that. They just had that one DM which I don't know. Can every
Can something be hearsay of yourself? Is that possible? I don't
know if it's possible or not. No, that's just your testimony.
You would testify that this person sent me this video. That would
just be your testimony. >> And you'd have to account for
the fact that you basically have to say that you have some evidence
that she looked through your computer. There would have to be
something there, right? I don't think he has that. >> Why
Why are you asking a question when you either just Googled or
you know the answer?
Why?
>> Wait, hold on. PJ forhead. >> This person sent
me >> call Abby to the stand and too. Oh, that guy's been
in my chat a couple times.
>> Weird. Weird. >> Why Why are you asking a question
when you either just Googled or you know the answer? The standard
December judge was looking at all the discovered evidence in
the light most favorable to the plaintiff. Correct. Yes. Um well,
most favored to the move um against the movement. Are you going
to read the amendment complaint? Um
>> uh free pie. The issue would be how do you get um he
said that the logs don't have those videos or he didn't send
her videos or something. But um I don't know. I don't know how
you prove that he didn't delete things given they're just one
side of his logs. >> I mean I could I guess they cut out
some stuff and they replaced it with more just like stupid [__]
I guess. >> Oh maybe. Is there anything else good here
or
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa. Where's Zip Zip when Destiny needs
them? God damn it. Start yapping. This why people settle. Yeah.
Like I have a feeling I don't know if he said it. I'm almost
positive he said it, right? Oh, that's what we're waiting for
here. He talks about like why he doesn't want to settle, but
um
I I think his lawyers told him just settle. Like you should just
settle this. I think they knew it would be like insanely expensive
and they're like yeah just settle it. It's obviously worth it
to settle it. Like she has some claim here. Don't risk this getting
in front of a jury. It's like just settle it, bro. >> Can
you directly say in a filing, I believe this person is lying.
This is what likely happened. No, I don't think you would ever
say that. I don't need to say that. They have no it's the onus
is on them to provide evidence for the claim, right? >> Well,
I think they're trying to provide evidence to get discovery,
right? Is what they're trying to do. They're basically saying
like this would be discovered through through seeing the Google
drive. Well, hello. Hello. comes down plaintiff Jane do under
count of the plaintiff
another photo right privacy public
face in this complaint and um publicized on our own social media
feeds but okay >> not with her name though
obviously a little different >> um and then defendant Stephan
Bonell II for some reason they are still misspelling my name
I don't know how but okay a citizen of the United States and
it was a live stream and a political commentator over 840 subs
on his YouTube channel he's twing X kick Reddit and Discord how
>> hold on uh he can't handle the reputational damage.
Like the damage is there, but he can't internalize it and accept
it. Yeah. I think the the issue is he used to he had like a thing
where he didn't want to be known as like some like weirdo, right?
He wanted to be a weirdo but not be known as a weirdo. And now
he's going to have that reputation for the rest of his life.
And I do think that's like quite frustrating for him. Like he
that's probably another reason he can't settle, right? is he
wants the win in court and if he doesn't get the like
he he's just going to ride it out for the win in court to try
to say like yeah I won so you can't call me this anymore but
even if he wins in court he still was sending the video around
right it's still like he is still a total weirdo like the I I
don't think the reputation ever heals at this point like because
of what's bolted on uh also
he didn't want to be known as weirdo and then he helped and was
was the key evidence provider in doxing the minor he was like
that's sort of the reputation's gone at that point right this
is over >> channel was banned from Twitch March 2022 due
to hateful conduct nice plaintiff known as pixie al is also a
live streamer as well as an in followers blog of my birthday
and they I don't I don't understand
with the link or anyone in the organization but I don't trust
the least restricted privacy setting for his Google drive link
anyone with the link this setting makes the sensitive material
accessible indefinitely to any third party possessing that link
this ongoing accessibility functionally equates to publicly posting
explicit content online. If this was the case, that would mean
that literally every single digital thing that you send counts
as being published and forever
No, only things that don't have like privacy settings. I do think
that the there's already um there's already precedent on this
that sufficiently
unique identifiers
will essentially count as a password and that
those won't be considered publicly available. So when you create
a public Google Drive link, it adds this UU ID to it. This uniquely
universally unique identifier that basically counts as like a
unique code that makes it unlikely anybody he argues the same.
There's literally precedent on it. We looked in when the when
the case first got brought, we looked into that case. I think
it's LinkedIn some some like LinkedIn case. Is it LinkedIn? And
there's another case with like um somebody had like a Google
Drive link that got exposed through a Facebook post and somebody
like grabbed those materials and the argument was oh they hacked
that
and the the guy who used it was like no I didn't hack it cuz
it was publicly available and it was declared like not publicly
available right because of the uniqueness of the URL. I I think
that is basically that that's that's precedent somewhere. But
the issue here would be if that drive was there then obviously
he would could be linking other people to that drive um after
the fact which would be linking it without linking the video
directly and I think that would count as continuous publishing.
If I link a Google Drive URL that is a folder and that folder
has the Pixie video in it that would count. So they might also
be arguing that >> like if somebody has a link or a file,
it literally doesn't like it's the same thing in effect, right?
But okay, >> it would have to be from some non it would
have to be some non-normalized
like URL structure, but I that's Google Drive is a UU ID. So
I think you're safe there. the um there there's there is core
precedent that people have tried to make this argument in the
past and it this is yeah it's not a real this is not a real argument
but >> oh there was a I I think there's a possible reading
of the precedent that could still say this doesn't count
but I can't remember what it was now I I watched it and I'm like
95% you don't get to make this argument that by creating that
URL you're making like a you're publishing
um and making it publicly available. I think 95% chance you can't
say that, right? But sending the URL to people would be another
instance of publishing or disseminating. And then that would
be in like the video case. In the video case, in the in the folder
case,
that would be big bad. That would be continuous publishing. That
would be because you'd be linking the video or folder that contains
the video every time. If you just had the URL for the video link,
I think that still counts as essentially private. That's not
really considered different than than a file itself. like directly
transmitting like if you directly transmitted it to one person
um and they directly transmitted to somebody else those would
be two independent events it wouldn't be like it's publicly available
because it's sitting there as a URL and somebody
yeah
I guess they try to make this one
um they've walked back the initial date to saying based on the
available evidence to date it cannot be conclusively determined
whether summation of the video occurred on April or October.
So the date here is important because if it's on April then this
law isn't in effect and the they have no case um they would have
a case of the Abby. You need them you need to you need all three
dominoes to follow the Google Drive continuous publishing thing
um that you didn't send the the like a folder link to people
that contained the Pixie video. And I think there they probably
do have some evidence to say like yeah I think you would have
sent a folder to people, right? I think they would have that
evidence.
Uh what else is there? And then there's two more. Uh then the
Abbey stuff and then the the date on the road stuff. The date
on the road stuff that domino falls for sure. I'm almost positive.
There's not a real contention here. Unless they legitimately
think there were 27 months in the year, uh this this is not real.
Um they try to get ahead of this Google Drive link and they try
to say that even if it was just sent as a video file on Discord,
even if it was not sent via a Google Drive link, but was sent
via a media attachment on Discord, it would still have been continuously
accessible. Discord automatically creates a link and anyone with
access to that. So that is something that could be so continuously
accessible. You could make this argument. I think they can't
possibly rule as precedent that having the continuously published
like link perpetually in those in those DMs. I don't think you
could make the argument that that's
like inst that counts as continuous publishing or else basically
every like folder every video you send is continuously continuously
published if you have the ability to delete it or something.
>> That link can access the video. Every video is automatically
embedded with a media attachment link. This link is a live link.
Defendant has demonstrated knowledge of this feature is routinely
discord video links into his public chat threads. The same analysis
applies to both sharing the videos through discord or sharing
the video as a Google Drive link. Again, this argument is like
immediately well hold on. If I were to share a digital file with
somebody, they could just spread the file just the same as if
I were to share a link with somebody. Like it's the same thing.
This is a nonsense argument. And again, there's already
um so the argument here would be the publicly accessible link.
The counter argument it's still a UU ID even in Discord. So,
I believe that that does not count as a publicly available URL.
Like, if you if you publish to Destiny's
really cool folder.com and you can just see everything there,
that would be publishing that would be publishing, right? But
like you're basically using um like a string with with like as
many combinations of that string as exist like atoms in the universe,
right? So, it's like just because you have one of those strings
doesn't mean somebody could type it or guess it or get into it
through inference somewhere. I think the case law I've seen that
counteracts this is um I don't remember if it was a ninth circuit
case or an 11th circuit case. I >> uh that is what they're
looking for specific is the ability to to subpoena Discord in
Google Drive. Yes.
>> Yeah, that's what they're looking for. >> Circuit
is Florida the fifth circuit or fourth? What circuit is Florida
in? Oh, 11th. Oh, maybe it was an 11th circuit case then. That's
good for me. Crazy. [__] Right. 1 2 3 4 Oh, 5 6 7
8 9 10 11. Weird. Okay. I read this case when it came out that
he's talking about with URLs and why they don't count as public
>> I don't think this is true. I don't have any proof of
this. I don't think there's any proof. I don't think this I don't
think I did a link or whatever, but anyone link it no account
else
constitute dissemination. I think they have to be very very careful
to I think they're running this argument down too hard then the
argument would literally just be that because I do know that
the way that I initially um sent my stuff back to Pixie was just
setting her Google Drive links. So if if we're going to make
the argument that that counts as publishing online, then she
consented and acquies to it immediately when she received the
link. This argument feels so stupid. I don't know why. Um H
I don't know if it applies both ways. Like she received the link
from you. I don't know if it applies to both way both ways. Um
yeah, I don't know. I kind of see what he's what he's saying
there that like oh if you're going to argue that that that should
be known as publicly disseminating that I sent it to her with
something that's publicly disseminated. Why didn't she freak
out about it?
Um
I don't think you could say she consent it just cuz you sent
it that way. Okay. Oh, well, I didn't ask cuz they're desperate,
but whatever.
Uh, I think that's really rough for him, though. Okay. I I actually
don't know why Pixie wouldn't have gotten like kind of freaked
by that. Wouldn't you get kind of spooked by that? Wait, why
do you have that on like a cloud drive?
That actually is kind of crazy that Pixie didn't get spooked
by that. And that it's on something like that would be Oh, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Um, dude, if he had an openly permissible link there,
that might be that might really him if there are access logs
for that link.
That would be really rough for him, I think. Sometime of March
of 2023, Bon began messaging with a fan on his uh of his on Instagram
over the course of their relationship. BMC multiple sex videos
through the Google Drive link videos sent Abby MC on the sugar
included one of the videos of plaintiff. Okay. She was uploaded
as insanely.
I don't know why this stupid idiot keeps putting like all of
this just in public filings for literally everybody to like it's
just the most outrageous stupid thing. This is like one of the
most This is why I don't believe the claims or any of this other
bull that she's saying. Yeah. I I don't know if Destiny realized
this. Um Pixie doesn't write these. Yeah. He's just he's like
sperking at Pixie. Pixie literally doesn't write
I don't know if he does he think is he writing pages or is he
writing documents for for himself or why does he think Pixie's
writing this like this is just a deeply unserious way to approach
it's just deeply unserious but soliny leaks started uh said online
that he accessed the videos that he posted on KB farms from links
to Bunnel's Google Drive so tiny was able to access the video
and then distributed confirms that B school should be an unschedu
Google drive link with the broadest possible privacy setting
enable ongoing continuous distribution and we're not onetime
events literally anybody that accesses anybody's digital device
has access to every single digital file on that device like that.
No, wait, but she he didn't Nobody accessed her device. It's
on the account. It's It's literally saying
uh It's fine. It's fine. You You have access on You'd have access
to the messages, I guess. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. He said device
and should he didn't have access to the device, but it is um
it's the account that had it. So, yeah. Even if it was a file,
the file would still be there. Sure. That's like I don't know
actually why I keep saying digital. This would be >> I
would say that if he ever linked something like a folder to somebody
that included the pixie thing that would count as uh continuous
distribution as >> If I gave you like a Polaroid like if
I gave you a picture
like if I gave you a Polaroid picture would that count as continuous
publishing? Like it's such a stupid argument. Shortly after the
video is posted various friends and random followers informed
about the summation video and the messages are very accusatory.
She is shocked humiliated and mortified by the simation which
was her video. As of today's date, the video has been I just
keep talking about the websites. Nice. Go jerk off to my
Oh, this is also true though that yeah, you could you could restrict
the uh Google Drive links to
like to like an email or
That would be Dude, I feel like I don't know why
you would get an unsecured Google Drive link of that contains
you and just go this is fine.
That seems insane to me. like really really dumb on Pixie's part.
Like obviously gross on Destiny's part for doing that in the
in the first place. I would just be like, "Bro, why the what
the [__] you doing making it like a publicly accessible
link of this? Are you out of your mind?" >> All right.
On the evening November 29th, 2024, plan to send a message about
on Discord expressing her horror. They share the video of her.
She asked me if he sent any additional videos to anyone. He admits
his guilt. Okay, not really, but we'll get through it, I guess.
Plan as delete any and all videos that he has of her. >> Oh,
hold on. I've had phone combos and stuff with this person. They
were fairly close to me. It's worthless to say, but at this point,
but I'm super sorry. There's literally no excuse.
Uh, there shouldn't be no. I'm so sorry. There's literally no
excuse. I have had I'd had phone convos and stuff with this person.
They were fairly close to me. They He met them max I think max
10 days earlier. For the first time spoke with them in DMs for
the first time 10 days earlier as somebody he had no affiliation
with, no no association with.
Right. Yes.
This is just this is just insane. And it's a window into who
he is as a person, right? This is like an insane absurd lie to
tell somebody.
And like I I don't know if he would even admit that this is just
an obvious lie. So he lie in court about this. I don't know if
he I don't know if he's responded to this quote specifically.
Dude, it's it's so crazy that he uh that he just makes >> video
goes viral and is being discussed by thousands of followers of
Destiny Pix on various platforms including YouTube, Discord,
Red.
Plaintiff begins receiving messages. Many of the followers discussing
leaks on their different accounts falsely claim the plaintiff
exchange for professional growth and favors from Bonell.
Okay. Plaintiff feels increasingly humiliated, mortified and
depressed and starts feeling suicidal. On about December 11th,
2024, she starts writing suicide notes. Plaintiff messages Bonell
and tells him that she is just tired of living anymore. It's
a matter of time till my family discovers what happened. Plaintiff
then unfriends Bon on Discord so that she cannot receive any
messages from him. I like how she doesn't admit that she asked
me for money to make it so this didn't happen, which is extortion
by the way, but okay. Honor about December 13th, 2024. Suicide
raised. Honor about December 13, 24.
Why would she mention that? It's her complaint. Why would she
mention that? Wouldn't that be really weird to mention in a complaint
when it's unrelated to this this uh thing? I I just feel like
that would be really weird.
Who confesses to other crimes in a complaint? By the way, I also
committed a crime
in a complaint. Unrelated crime. I just committed a totally unrelated
crime, guys. Yeah, I know it's weird to put that in my complaint,
but I just put in my complaint to be intellectually >> Bunnel's
close friend um and business associate color Turner plaintiff
tells her about her thoughts that she cannot bear the humiliation
and harassment she is enduring and that she >> really really
destiny, you're just going to dox not so aerodite live on your
stream, Destiny, you're just going to dox not soite.
That's crazy. wants to ensure Bonell never does this to her or
anyone else ever again.
Yes, by being forced to give her a million dollars.
>> Guys, this is absolutely
disgusting.
Oh my god. But I guess um she doesn't mention that. Okay. Turner
tells her she talked about tell them what they discussed on her
about December 19th. Turner asks plaintiff if Bal has communicated
with her or added her back as a friend. Plentif negative. Plaintiff
continues feeling depressed and the video is still a viral topic
of conversation on multiple platforms. So this is not true. Um,
people are not talking about her video at all. Mo uh with people
making
>> this is just wrong. >> Horrible accusations about
plaintiff. On the morning of January 20, 25, two videos on YouTube
are posted by two different streamers discussing the pixie leak.
Videos include screenshots of private messages of plaintiffs
discussing the situation with friends and claims the plaintiff
took hush money, only cares about money and does not care about
the other victims of defendant. These videos have been viewed
by thousands, including one which of today was viewed by over
90,000 people. Majority of the post by people, assume that Bon
share the videos with plaintiff's consent and knowledge. Honor
about January 2025. in desperation. Um, this is a lie. We see
I've seen her DMs with um Aaron like they're publicly. You can
see them on the videos. She had already crafted her statement
at least a week earlier. So, this wasn't out of desperation.
She was always planning on doing this, but she pretends that
she was forced by these videos. Plant Wait, both of those things
could be true. How does Why does he pretend to not understand
that both both of these things could be true, right?
You could be planning to sue him as like a last Yeah. It's like
a last stitch effort, right? There's nothing to even know for
sure that she wouldn't have reached out again to be like, "Hey,
I've like retained legal counsel. I'm going to I'm going to try
one last time to see if we could solve this in person or or solve
this with through some other means." Right? Like there's no reason
to say just cuz she crafted her statement and looked into legal
counsel that she would have sued you no matter what. But she
was pushed to by the videos breaking/pixie goes online and announces
that the destiny share the videos without her concern knowledge
and that she'll be seeking legal recourse. That same day, Bunnel
says you're responsible on various platforms, including Reddit
I imager, and falsely claims that the video leak happened without
my knowledge, consent, or authorization. Um, they're trying to
play this weird game where like when I say leak, obviously I'm
talking about the guy that posted 30 videos online, and they
try to say leak is just sending the video to anybody. So, they
play this word game back and forth a lot. This claim directly
contradicts his November 29th, 2024, explicit written admission
plowing and intentionally share the video with Rose without plaintiff's
consent. That is not the claim, but okay. on January 20th after
plaintiff announced publicly went out directly contradict his
November 29th 2024 explicit written admission to plaintiff. Oh
no, you you did this twice. You actually like acknowledged to
multiple people that you that you did this. >> One of his
followers Oh, and she still includes all these we >> It's
like by the way this is so much worse than his like walk back
of the rose sharing. This is actually so much worse that he like
in multiple conversations with multiple people. Basically admitted
he shared it without without consent, right? Without knowing
if he had consent, without an explicit certainly without an explicit
conversation about consent. Weird hearsayer double hearsay things
even though they have no evidence of this. And in a hearing they
said that all these people deleted their accounts. On January
20th, right after plaintiff announced publicly she would sue
Bonell. One of his followers reached out to plaintiff and told
her that Bonell had >> uh hold on just to be clear. You're
you're basically right, Tequila Sunset. You're in in effect right.
But Eric conferred to Turkey that she asked us if he had a cassette
and he said, "I don't think so." No. Like I don't think so. So
it was one of those things where he always leaves like a little
bit of plausible deniability there. I don't think so. I don't
think I did have consent. I don't think so. I don't remember
for sure, but I don't think so. >> Sent the video to her
sister about 2 months earlier. The follower informs plaintiff
that she believes. >> Oh, they left that
to share the videos by me.
>> Okay, we need to get through this because I want to
get to the actual part where he talks about this years ago, but
it was just showing that she was trying to me. I wasn't trying
to do any weird but but the um
um no one is doing anything. Yeah, but good one. The videos disclosed
by Bonell were of a private nature were never intended for public
distribution. Defense actions cause plenty of severe mot. Okay.
And then this is just the Jesus and forgets who Dylan Burns is.
I saw that clip earlier. What do we got on the docket for today?
Wait. Horse crotch snake.
Do you have any proof of that or you know ABMC is being squirly
with Jane Doe's lawyers because she's trying to get compensation
for her testimony. She doesn't want to do it for free. >> That's
by the way just a perfect window into his mind, right? Is that
not a perfect window into his mind? He's like, "Wait, do you
know that?" Like, wait, is Abby really trying to get money from
them? Like, he's just he's hopeful of like any positive news
at this point. I did as like a window into how well things are
going. Wait, random chatter. Do you have evidence about my court
case that would save me? Random chatter. Oh my god. Horse crutch
thing. What was it? Horsec crutch
snake. Horse crotch snake. Do you have Do you have evidence that
would help me, please? Amazing. This reads more like an attempt
at cancellation with the amount of random [__] in
there. Yeah, I mean that's basically what they're doing. They're
just trying to like throw random [__] in. Like again,
the the only only thing that really matters now is the AbbyMC
thing, which is who the >> I I find it so funny that he
talks about how disgusting Pixie is, but at the same time, he
did so much more to hurt his own reputation by Doxing Rose by
being the
the number one information provider for Doxing Rose,
right? Like like he could talk about how disgusting Pixie is
and how she's like tried to ruin his reputation, but he ruined
his reputation so much more by proving that he was minor than
anything Pixie has done or could have done,
right? Everybody was willing to write Pixie off. Okay, Destiny
had he laid the groundwork for that same defense. These guys
are these people are mentally ill. He he laid the groundwork
for that a thousand times in the past. He was skating. He was
on easy street for that one, right? And then then he had to go
and prove to the world that he was a minor and lying about the
amount of information he had for finding her. It's just
it's incredible cuz I think later in this he'll talk about how
Pixie is the most disgusting person he's ever met. She's just
totally disgusting. And it's like bro she can't do she couldn't
do you know with all of her power the might of $50,000 and the
outrage of like the entire internet she couldn't do onetenth
of the the reputational harm that you did to yourself by doxing
rose. I don't know. >> It's um if she actually >> he
can never go low in a debate now cuz they'll just call him a
>> Yeah, that's the thing is like he's like kind of eternally
cocked now. He just gets to be a unic for like the rest of his
time on the internet. Like he he was able to get back at Ethan,
right? Cuz Ethan has a 20-year career where Ethan says insane.
But for most of the people he talks to, especially in politics,
he doesn't want a bunch of clips of people laughing at him and
calling him a right. Like that was the last thing he wants with
Taylor Loren. He doesn't want Taylor Loren laughing at him and
asking, you know, did you really see a 17-year-old? Did you really
prove that you like did you really like dox her and with with
Kiwi Farms and prove that she was 17? Are you a [__]
Right. So, he can't be rude. He can't be rude. The Wick Dono
clip. Wait, are you talking about uh the Molina one? He's talked
so much about Taylor Loren, but in the call he was so soft. Yeah,
I know. It's amazing. Philly did get brain damage from that car
accident and that's like explanatory of all her behavior over
the past year and a half. That would be really sad. It would
be even more crazy that Pixie's taking advantage of her to try
to keep her case. Dude, this No.
Uh Abby Abby had like uh Aby's got like a lot of stuff going
on. Um she had like addiction issues and stuff and it's pretty
well documented online and it's like it's sad but people were
taking advantage of her the whole time including Destiny, including
this guy. And then he sits here and he's like, "It'd be really
disgusting if Pixie took advantage of her more than I took advantage
of her by flying her out to Miami." You know, like,
bro, you can't you can't sit here and and concern troll about
people taking advantage of someone who's mentally ill when you
flew that person out and them like like, you can't do it, right?
You can't concern troll about this and about her mental illness,
right? She can make decisions. She has
It's so performative. She can make those
She can decide to fly out to you. She can decide to sue you.
She can decide to give testimony to Pixie.
She can do those things >> alive. Just intuition. Oh, good
one, buddy. What about the dismissal? Um, well, I imagine next
I think we try to file a motion to dismiss. But again, on the
pleading stage, the judge is supposed to read all the facts of
the complaint as though all the facts are true. So, it would
be surprising if he dismissed it here, but I don't know. We'll
see. He the fact that but Destiny I thought you said that it
was obvious he was going to dis sorry not obvious that there's
a chance he'd dismiss it himself without even a motion.
I thought he was I thought this was getting dismissed. Bro, what
happened? Listen guys, in a week or two this will be dismissed.
It'll all be over. Record scratch. Cut to 6 months later. I guess
you guys are wondering how I ended up here. Well, it's a it's
quite the story. Okay. It's quite it's quite the story. >> That
he invited one I think is nice. But >> that he invited
one.
Did he invite one or was he basically like, "Stop yapping about
how there's no subject matter jurisdiction if you're not going
to move to dismiss, loser." Like, it's pretty obvious he knows
that there is subject matter jurisdiction here and you should
just shut up about it. You should stop putting in your pleadings.
But he's basically like, "If you want to solve this question,
file the correct paperwork to solve this question." It's actually
the same thing that happened to Pixie when she went to the TTRO
hearing when she was like, "I actually want an order saying he
can't destroy evidence." And they're like, "Hey [__]
you already got one of those." And if you if you want to sanction
him or if you want to do something, there's like other things
you should do. There's totally different procedures you should
follow.
Yeah. It's uh he he's doing the judge is doing that same thing
to Destiny now. Different judge, though. So, did the gag order
not work? There is no gag order. They were well they they were
kind of asking for effectively what would be a gag order, but
the judge noticed that they were being tricky with the for effectively
what would be a gag, but the judge noticed that they were being
tricky with the um they not the judge noticed that they were
being tricky with
>> they sent us a motion to agree to and then we did but
the one they filed with the court was completely different. So
the judge denied that one and granted basically the motion is
granted in part just like an an ordinary protection order over
discovery information.
Uh, I don't think they made any ruling on the public speaking.
I don't think they made a ruling on that.
Is he trying to imply they made a ruling on that? I think that
protective order with regards to public statements,
I think that motion is still alive. So, whatever we trade back
and forth on discovery, we can't like post publicly, especially
in a case like this, I mean, it's kind of fair. Can you expand
on your take on the Google Drive link argument? Why is whether
the link is public or private not an important difference? Cuz
it's having a link is the same thing. Like a file is is basically
the same thing. It's all just digital data, right? Like if you
send me a Google link,
it's not really I mean
except for maybe through some maybe hack, but like let's say
you send me like a link to a file versus you sending me the file
itself.
My ability to transfer that file to anybody else is the exact
same, right?
No, technically you could put it in other places. It's uh like
every platform allows text, not every platform allows attachments.
There's probably like a bunch of different reasons why a link
would be easier to share, why a link would be me, more meaningful
to share. But like what I would say is I don't think having that
link, the existence of that link is not proof that somebody could
find it through the broader internet, that it is a continuing
publication of that video is more where the argument has to go.
So he's trying to make that argument. I don't think that argument
is quite as good. The argument that he's probably referencing
that there is case
uh I think there's already existing case law existing uh precedent
on is that a uniquely unique identifier in the URL is basically
going to make it so that that counts as um like something sort
of password semi password protected that the privacy setting
is not necessarily like open to the public as if you publish
it on a website in the same way like say you send me a picture
of your mom versus sending me a link to a picture of your mom
it's the same thing I can I can you do the same.
Like, did >> Yeah, this is also true. Free specific. Yeah,
this is also true. Like, and I would say because it's being put
into Discord. In Discord, you can actually for all of the exporters,
you can export without videos, without media, or with media,
right? There's like a whole bunch of reasons. >> Send him
my thing. Oh, no, no, don't worry. I didn't send him a thing.
I didn't send I didn't send him that thing. I just sent him a
link to your thing. It's like, "Oh, okay. Thank god." But the
funny thing is there was I think it was an 11th Circuit case.
Um, there was a case where somebody tried to make that argument
because somebody apparently messed up and posted a Google Drive
link publicly. I think they posted the link publicly and they
there was a link on a picture in the background of some photo
they posted on Facebook and then somebody accessed that and everybody
said well it's not hacking cuz you made it public and it's like
well
because it was like publicly accessible the the privacy setting
was set to public and it's like well the URL was sufficient such
that nobody could find it so to say it was public is not really
>> included the link up top and it was a public link and
then the um
but the judge ruled that that didn't count as public disclosure
because I don't remember what the argument was, but even that
didn't count as public disclosure. So, >> I've given it
to you cuz I actually read this stuff. No, I actually just got
lucky and read this one cuz I >> Are you able to say why
you believe they deleted evidence, Pixie? Because she knew she
was cuz she knew she was trying to extort me. And my guess is
going to be that Lauren and her were probably going over the
conversations and Lauren probably told her, "You have to delete
this part cuz this is like there's a reason why there was >> Let
me just s Source decided crackpipe.
source decided just a big old crackpipe right now. >> Specific
dollar amount brought up with me. I think all she complained
about was that any the because the thing in her first message
was one of the things she said when I said uh if I could help
or whatever she said I think that what was it? It's in one of
my it's in the mini fester I read about this. She said that um
I feel like any dollar amount that I ask for you're going to
say no to and that's just going to make me feel even worse. And
that's the message that she deleted. Maybe because it's the one
that came the closest to like bringing up a dollar amount to
me, but my guess is Lauren told her to delete that message. But
also, um yeah, also when I looked at it, it's funny actually
because I think a hater posted this or sent me some DM. Uh and
I didn't realize this until way too late. I don't think I even
>> Oh, this will be the argument >> that um I don't
think I even sent that video as a Google Drive link. So, none
of that even >> Dude, I pointed that out the second they
made that argument the first time that they obviously posted
as like a Discord. You obviously posted as a Discord attachment.
Like that's obvious from the uh that's obvious from the the text
messages from the export, right? He didn't send a Google Drive
link with the Pixie video. He literally sent the video. He like
uploaded the video. >> Even applies to this. So this all
but even if it did, it's all this is stupid. Yeah. How did she
even come up with 15 million? I have no idea. She took the statutory
maximum and multiplied it by >> 15 millions. By the way,
he's like I would I would have maybe paid her like 50k or something.
It's like, bro, to to litigate this case, she has a she has a
case that would have subject matter jurisdiction that wouldn't
just be dismissed, that she's got evidence that she could go
to court with.
It will cost you so much money. That is a part of unfortunately
settling a court case. I It's It's not really fair, is it? It's
not totally fair, but it's like, what would it cost you to defend
yourself here? Is there a case, right? And how much would it
cost her to prosecute the case? Well, unfortunately for you,
like it's not going to cost her that much money. It's going to
cost you way more money. And then you hired the most expensive.
He's like actually himself by hiring the most expensive lawyer
he could. I don't know that Andrew Breler has like saved him
in any way up until this point.
I don't know that it's like necessarily helped over just any
random law firm, but he's paid like probably double what you
pay a standard law firm. It's like if you're going to take this
to trial, if you're going to refuse to settle, why not pay somebody
who's not going to charge you like an arm and a leg every time
every time you file a >> I still think you would have been
better off paying her off. Uh, Alpha Kilo, just so you know,
we've already we've already said it. Okay, Pixie Lawyers, Joan
Joan Schlump Peters, Joan Schlump Peters, if you can hear this.
Okay, I'm I'm calling out through the ether through the Cabal
No, no, no. Telepathic communication network. Okay, the Cabal
Telepathic Communication Network. Joan Schlump Peters, can you
hear me? Joan Schlump Peters, can you hear me? Can you hear me?
I hear you. I hear I hear you. I Joan, I hear you. We we we formed
the connection, Joan. I need you to file an what they call an
Irata. Okay. Uh an update of an erroneous filing. Yeah. You you've
stated Rose is seven is 19 in your amended complaint. You need
to update her her age. She She was 17. She was she was 17. Joan.
Joan. She was 17.
Joan, you have to update it. Joan, you must you must update it.
Joan, >> what paying are a million? >> Oh, Alpha
Kilo. All that is to say is they say it's a 19-year-old named
Rose in the complaint
and
they could just update that to a 17-year-old. That that that
should be on the record for sure. Yes, we do need that on the
record. Joan. Joan, please. Joan. Joan.
I think
uh I'm pretty sure people who watch this stream do email Joan
sometimes. So, listen. SS
if you're hearing this. SS, if you're hearing this, I need you
to send another email to Jode and just make her aware that 17
should be age on the record. Okay? Should be the age on the record.
SS, if you hear me now, okay, if you're watching the VOD tomorrow
morning, SS, this is a communication. We million dollars. No,
that's crazy. Hold on. >> I still think you would have
been better off paying her off. What? Paying her a million dollars?
Uh, I think for the reputation hit. Yeah, he might have gotten
out of this. He really might have gotten out of this entirely
if he just if he just paid like her and Molina off 500k each
or something, right? And may and Sasha too.
Sasha deserves to get paid for that, right? For the violation
and and she deserves that. I I think Pixie and Molina were the
people with platforms and the people who his fans knew and the
people who if they weren't speaking out against him, he might
not uh have any
I think those are the ones Millie to keep this all behind the
scenes. If he could spend a million dollars to keep this all
behind the scenes or mostly behind the scenes, right? I think
he should have and I think it's insane to say otherwise. >> No,
that's crazy. Is Lauren just out of any interactions? I haven't
heard about her in a long time. She's just a weirdo behind the
scenes.
By the way, I just want to point out that Zip Zip knew 100% that
filing to dismiss was yesterday and he didn't point it out because
he didn't want Destiny to be mad at him on stream. That's why
Destiny came back today was like, "Yeah, I don't think we I don't
think we get to dismiss, guys. I don't think that'll work." >> Apparently,
a lot of people are saying good things about this Dexter Resurrection
show. Was it Is it >> Okay, the Dexter Resurrection Show
is good. It is good. It is actually really good. Even though
it's a continuation of the Alaska series season, which was awful.
Um, it is actually really, really good. No, it's actually good.
It's having a little bit of the issue that the Alaska one did
where it's like kind of weaving at the very end
maybe, but it's still way better than everything before like
season 6 or sorry after season 6 the original season or original
show. The Alaska season was decent until the end. It really dude
they they managed to like lumberjack it right at the end. It
was stupid. >> Actually good.
>> Yeah. How do you do that twice? How do you get the cast
back together for like a comeback season and you lumberjack it
again? How in the world? >> How can Isn't this like the
third or fourth show? >> Say Koko. >> Yes, but this
one is actually really good. It's Ultronormy slap. Do not >> It
doesn't matter. The first Dexter the first like two or three
Dexter seasons. The first two for sure. I'd say even the first
four are great. They're all awesome. Three is Miguel Pra, right?
Season one is Ice Truck Killer. Season two is
What is season two? Why can't I remember season two? Oh, it's
Dos, right? It's Dos
and him.
Season three is Miguel Pra Pra. Season four is Trinity. Yeah.
First four are amazing. Season five is Yeah. Laya and Dos. Yeah.
Yeah. Laya and Dos. Season five is
Julia Styles.
Yeah. Julia Styles. That season was a little better. I I rewatched
not too long ago and the Julia Styles season was
then I remembered it being I think it was actually okay.
I thought it was really bad when I watched it and then I rewatched
it and it was like ah
it's not the worst. Yeah. But if you really liked if if you really
liked the first four seasons of Dexter and feel like it fell
off and it just never quite and the ending was so bad, the fact
that it might get an actual good ending to the series is like,
"Oh, that just feels better." Okay, there's like a hole in my
life. All right, imagine if they could fix Game of
Imagine if they could fix Game of Thrones, like the ending somehow,
right? It'll make you It would just feel better not knowing that
it didn't get like that your original excitement wasn't totally
like wasted. We just feel better. Okay. We just feel better.
I feel like Rob Trapped into a pointless scam last night. Of
course tied Trump to Russia because the evidence showed a tie
between them. That's why the media kept asking questions about
it. Well, no. Rob played a game. I don't know if it'd be worth
going back over. Um, Rob played a little game where he tried
to say the whole point of
him bringing up the Clinton plan and the fabricated email from
Russia was to prove that the idea of tying Trump to Russia was
an artificial plot concocted in the Hillary camp. But by the
time we excruciatingly wrestled through every single minor point
of evidence, by the time we got to the end, he said, "Oh, no."
I never claimed that they got that idea. I just was saying that
they were doing oppo.
Most disgusting person I think I've ever interacted with. >> Oh,
there we go. I was like I was like, did we get past the >> to
that level of expense? Hopefully
mission again. That was Yeah. Oh my god.
>> Sorry. Here we go. Wait, did he lose to Rob? There's
no way he Wait, did he lose? He lost to Rob, too. Lil Bro can't
even debate anymore. Oh, boy. There's no way he lost to Rob,
too, right? >> You're going to come out of this whole situation
minus 1 mill anyway. No. So, would it make sense to to settle
outside of court and avoid all this? Uh, I don't think I'll get
to that level of expense. Hopefully, uh, by the time it's all
said and done, hopefully we're under 600k. >> How is he
spending 95K a month, but he's under 600k, >> which is
still pretty gross. Um, but I would pay 600K to prevent her from
getting 100K or whatever. That would just never >> Well,
it's good to see not just his politics are spite based. Okay.
Spitebased accounting, spite based monetary decision-m
I would spend I would spend so much money to prevent her from
making any. Bro, this is like your this is your king of like
facts and logic over here. Apparently,
my god.
Maybe only one month was 95. Yeah,
>> He's the most disgusting person I think I've ever interacted
with at this point in my entire [__] life. Like I'll
burn through some cash to make it
Uh, who is the more disgusting person, Nick Fentes or Pixie?
Obviously Pixie. Bad empanad or Pixie? Obviously Pixie. Pixie
is a terrorist and a white supremacist. She's a a terrorist and
a doxer and somebody who threatens people's lives all at the
same time. What a [__] Most disgusting person I've
ever dealt with in my entire life. So, she's not getting any.
Especially if knowing that the way that this all ends up Oh,
oh, he dealt with MS. Also, she's >> and seeing all the
filings. Like, she'll probably get dragged by the end of this,
too. So, her like, I'm I'm okay with that. Her behavior should
have been no point. Why would I reward that, right? >> Because
you'd be saving yourself, cutting your nose off despite your
face.
It's transparent. >> There might have been. Also, I will
say though, this is what happens by the way, when you have like
a cult of personality. You lose touch with reality so badly that
you like just start saying you just start like you think you
can weave reality. Like you fabricate reality and people just
like clap like seals around you. Isn't that terrifying?
I feel like I have an ego, but I've almost always had friends
who will tell me that I'm wrong on things. And I like prioritize
keeping those friends around cuz I'm always worried about like
letting my ego get inflated. Like I've I think I've been pretty
consistent about that in my life. Like always trying to make
sure I have at least one or two people around me who will be
like brutally honest with me.
And I just can't imagine getting to the place where you only
have um only have sick events and you like think you're just
correct about everything all the time. >> Though there
might have been some wiggle room for some kind of negotiation,
but she destroyed all of that when she posted the >> uh
Substack. As soon as she posted the
>> um her chances of of getting anything were deleted.
But my guess is she's probably from a rich family anyway. I guess
if she can waste cuz you know she's not spending.
He knows she's not from a rich family.
He literally knows.
Bro, you were on a call with her dad. Did it look like they were
living in a rich area?
Remember Remember when his when Pixiey's dad got on a call with
Destiny and Pixie and was like, "Thank you for taking care of
my daughter. Thank you.
I I don't know why I did his voice like that." Okay. I don't
know what the accent was. I don't I I'm not even gonna We're
gonna move on. All right. Her legal fees at this point must be
in excess of 50k. and she hasn't mentioned anything publicly
about spending any of the money that she fundraised. So my guess
is >> well she spent the money that she fundraised on lawyers.
>> Her parents probably are just paying for all of this.
It's a family friend family favor and then she just pocketed
the 50k cuz she doesn't make any money. >> Oh more creative
writing. My guess is they're going to take this pro bono know
that she got 50k through a gofundme and they're actually going
to take no money to work on this case. That's my guess. That
might be the dumbest guess I've ever heard in my entire life.
Oh right, dude. Dude, dude, dude, dude. Yes. Aaron literally
told Destiny, "Yeah, this [__] is hard up for cash.
She can't even afford POS podcasting equipment." Destiny knows
this. Possibly teeny tiny Tony. Destiny will in all other cases
understand that money is fungeable, right? That if she has to
spend 50k on so he's got to make up that like she's I guess getting
this stuff proono even though the lawyers would know she has
like access to funds explicitly earmarked for her legal case.
I
I have no idea. Yeah, it makes no sense, right? And
the funniest thing about that like stupid food shops theory is
she was comparing it to Keeffles. Keeles who was spending a bunch
of money on like gifts and travel and a new place like a full
year lease she paid like her rent up front. There's like no evidence
of a court case, no evidence of any action with lawyers and every
piece of evidence that she was spending money like hand over
fist.
Pixie, she literally immediately filed. She literally immediately
started paying lawyers to work for her. Although apparently Brianna
Woo found the first lawyer. I've been hearing >> online
anyway. It's my guess. The New Yorker Woo found Pixie's first
lawyer. I thought that's what Destiny said. Destiny talked about
this on on like a sentent food shop something some rashed for
inviting pro 911 radicals per who called Israelis inbred to speak
at festival. uh more evidence that people would rather
people would rather associate with the guy who said 9/11 America
deserved 911 and the guy who totally
they they could believe everything that he's a massive anti-semite
that he supported 911 that he hates America that he supports
terrorism and they would still rather hang out with Hassan [__]
than Destiny
unlucky buddy unlucky comment writer arc when I've heard Kimu
was watching that is that is it like an anime
I I mean I' I I know I've heard of it as an anime. Yeah. Oh,
wait. No, it's a live. It's It's a live action. No, I'm not going
to do it. Oh, it's a new thing on Prime Video. Oh, not new. Old.
Yeah. No, I'm probably not going to watch it. I'm sure it's good.
It's like rated our power rangers based.